I I'll share a secret with you which is
I am human yes of course I suffer all
the same and enjoy all the same emotions
as every other human being I do get down
of course I get down the thing that I'm
really good at is when I have down
feelings I do not deal with them alone I
call friends and uh sometimes I want
those friends just to listen and hold
space and sometimes I need advice from
people and I call multiple friends about
the same issue always I have a strict
rule which is no crying alone as if
you're overwhelmed by anything work
personal whatever it is and you feel it
coming you pick up the phone and you
call a friend and you say do you have a
minute can I just talk this through with
you and I've obeyed that since covet
began and my friends have obeyed it too
no crying alone